I've always enjoyed the MCU but I think
Ant-Man Quantum Mania is a straw to
break Marvel's back phase 4 was
definitely Rocky with movies like
eternals Black Widow Thor love and
thunder and doctor strange but at least
those movies were all relatively
self-contained and were set with the
tasks of telling an in-between story
from the infinity Saga to the Multiverse
Saga Marvel was starting to tear under
the sheer quantity they were outputting
during phase 4 and now that Ant-Man
Quantum Mania was supposed to be the
front runner that rocks everyone leading
into phase 5 and it being disappointing
is upsetting initially I wasn't going to
do this review but I got a little fired
up on letterboxed so I'll structure this
video in a similar way and won't make it
overly long first let's go into the
writing now I'm going to be honest with
you guys I think this is one of the
worst MCU scripts that has been put to
the screen so far which sucks because I
had hope for Jeff loveness given that he
wrote some great episodes for Rick and
Morty the usual Marvel inclusion of
humor rarely works once again and
detracts from the big dramatic
requirement the movie needs given the
mass Stakes one main reason it doesn't
work here in comparison to other Marvel
movies is because some scenes are solely
based on Comedy like the glub Shadow
hole scene that was just odd instead of
the humor being reserved for fast quips
it takes a focus a lot of the time and
it hurts entire scenes since this isn't
a quick small sticks Adventure like the
first two Ant-Man movies I think this
big blend of humor doesn't mix as well
because quipping is fine every now and
then but seems that should have more of
a dramatic Focus don't because of the
humor the dialogue also feels really
lazy like just throwing Quantum in front
of things like the prior movies do you
guys just put the word Quantum in front
of everything
like a satellite for deep space but
Quanah Michael Douglas saying ants in
every other sentence which only made me
think of this promo
and no real sense of wit in any moment
the movie was never able to get me to
care about the characters talking to
each other and a major aspect that
relies on this was Cassie and Scott's
relationship it feels really tacked on
for this movie and the creators don't do
enough to make you care about their
relationship considering that the Crux
of the movie depends on their strong
bond some dramatic beats fall short
because of this lack of connection
between them also a lot of the Sci-Fi
elements are overly goofy like the
controls of an alien ship having condom
joysticks the writing feels like
whatever random wacky [__] the writer
wants to throw on screen instead of
having any semblance of coherency I just
constantly felt detached from this world
because if flat out doesn't make sense
when the writer makes no attempt at
breathing logic into this world now
having wacky sci-fi Concepts is fine but
when you unload dozens of random
elements in every scene that aren't
complementary then it starts to feel
like an AI is generating the world for
you then the plot is not original enough
for how much time a gallivant surround
pretending to be Star Wars and he wish
it was a movie primarily about Kang
because when he's around the movie
quickly becomes significantly better
that's the only reason why I'd give this
movie a two out of five once he's on
screen the tempo for Quantum Mania
changes instantly in all humor
evaporates the disparity in quality
between the wacky opening hour and the
King scenes are so massive to the point
that if you just isolated King's scenes
then this movie becomes a 4 out of five
that's why I think this movie has such a
big divide between critics and and fans
fans will primarily focus on how awesome
Kang is while overlooking the faults the
movie undoubtedly has which you should
just be here for King at the end of the
day so if you enjoyed the movie more
than other people then that's fine but
as an overall package this movie is
extremely rough I can't really go into
detail about all the unique writing
issues because the movie isn't out yet
but for once I think an MCU movie has
enough problems with the script to make
a devoid of logic video normally there
are some contrivances and bad writing
choices tied to Marvel movies but I
think Quantum Mania crosses the line and
there's just so much wrong with the
script going into the visual side of
things this has the same issue as Thor
love and thunder where most of the set
is just the ground and everything else
is CGI while simultaneously trying to
increase the scale the creators also
strip away the authenticity because
everything feels fake it's hard to get
immersed when the actors can barely
interact with their surroundings and it
also leads to the most Bland
cinematography because how can the
cinematographer really get good footage
when there's almost nothing practical on
set it basically just comes down to the
previous team to deliver iconic images
that are primarily driven by CGI this
reminds me of Star Wars again because
for how much practical elements that are
within that film series it really makes
that world feel real and grounded while
quantumania feels like it's on the
opposite end of that Spectrum then the
VFX isn't as bad as everyone loves to
say although I did spot a couple errors
but it has some weird design choices and
it's overloaded in every single frame
making each shot feel overwhelming one
of the weird design choices was Modoc I
know he's supposed to look weird but
they shouldn't have scaled up his face
by 400 and called it a day looking at
his Comic version in comparison to the
movie version is hilarious for the
acting and characters the only person
here who gives a good performance is
Jonathan Majors he deserves a lot more
for hard carrying this movie everyone
else though has their own distinct issue
that hinders them Paul Rudd to me can't
carry this big dramatic baggage because
of how much comedic lines he has to keep
rattling off in every scene again tying
back to Thor needing to be dramatic but
having a hard time fulfilling that some
of his moments with Kang do resonate
really well because the humor disappears
and that's the tone the movie should
have had more of although that aspect of
the movie would have been better if the
father and daughter bond was Stronger
for Catherine noon she was never able to
excel because of how generic Cassie
Lange is she feels like a cookie cutter
character and her only motivation in
life is to do good and help people so
yeah there's not much there for her to
be that interesting and the movie
quickly throws us into the quantum realm
so her introduction is very brief then
for Hope Van Dyne she felt like a
background character in the movie she
doesn't really lead any scene for
dialogue and she just feels like she's
along for the ride I'm surprised the
movie is called Ant-Man and the WASP
consomania because of how little she has
to do in the plot for Hank Pym I
genuinely believe Michael Douglas
regrets joining the MCU it feels like he
isn't trying anymore in some scenes
which probably has to do with the script
and making him say ants all the time but
he just seems bored like there are a few
moments where the characters are in a
big plane of CGI vomit and Michael
Douglas is just like yeah man I just
don't care about what's happening right
now then Michelle Pfeiffer is supposed
to be intriguing but since the script is
so contrived she's not allowed to tell
anyone The crucial information she holds
until later in the movie like if she
actually opened her mouth in the
beginning then none of this would have
happened Ant-Man quantumania really
makes you wish we could go back to the
time of Captain America Winter Soldier
because there the scripts felt so much
better they weren't perfect by any means
but at least they weren't a jumbled mess
and told a more riveting narrative I
don't know if I'm slowly changing and
not liking the MCU anymore because the
people next to me loved it and the
theater was laughing hysterically at
every joke to quote the people next to
me that was fire bro it was [__]
amazing so yeah everyone has their own
taste and I'm falling on the side of the
crowd who didn't like the movie there
are some other massive issues I I have
with the movie regarding spoilers but if
you've seen it then you know Humpty
Dumpty was done dirty but thank you for
watching and let me know what you guys
thought about Ant-Man Quantum Mania